U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
has urged the governments to end what he
calls an orgy of Destruction as a
biodiversity Summit kicks off in Canada
at its opening in Montreal Gutierrez
warned Humanity has become a weapon of
mass extinction and that it must change
course now many experts are calling the
summit a final chance to save the world
species and ecosystems as we know them
the bones of an elephant poached for its
Ivory in Kenya images like these servers
a very visible reminder of the threat
that humans post to animal and plant
life deforestation changes in land use
the climate crisis and pollution are
also taking a big toll about 1 million
species are currently at risk of
becoming extinct due to human activity
this not only threatens to degrade
ecosystems further but also endangers
our own welfare
we depend on biodiversity for the food
we eat the water we drink
the sequestration of carbon
the medicines we take for instance 70
percent of cancer drugs come from
biodiversity or nature the UN
biodiversity conference will Center on
how to protect 30 percent of land and
sea by 2030. scientists stress that this
target is needed to prevent the collapse
of ecosystems and human prosperity in
the future
and unless our relationship with nature
changes the situation will continue to
deteriorate
I'm saying so because 97 of the global
biodiversity is degraded as the result
of Human Action we need to take urgent
measures to protect ourselves from
ourselves experts argue but who will
cover the costs
some emerging and developing economies
such as Indonesia India Brazil South
Africa and the Democratic Republic of
Congo tend to be particularly rich in
biodiversity but these countries argue
that they lack the resources to expand
their conservation efforts they are
demanding financial support from richer
Nations we don't want to see
a Target
which has absolutely no hope of
implementation scientists say there is
no time to lose however even if the
cop-15 participants set an ambitious
Target it can only be the beginning none
of the biodiversity objectives agreed at
the 2010 convention have yet been fully
implemented by the global community
Rondon joins us now from our environment
desk he's been following this for us
there's so much at stake at this
conference just walk us through what it
is
so ultimately this conference is about
stopping the destruction of of the
Planet of the life on this planet
um and as we just heard in the report
we're a long way off actually achieving
those goals so I mean just to give a bit
of context the biggest scientific study
of all the life on Earth found just a
few years ago that nature is declining
at unprecedented rates and the rates of
which we're pushing species to
Extinction is getting faster and faster
and faster and so the sort of thing that
this conference uh is the party that
this conference are trying to agree on
are policies to do things like
protecting 30 of the land and sea from
Human interference doing things about
the huge amounts of fossil fuel
subsidies and other environmentally
destructive subsidies that essentially
taxpayers are using governments are
using taxpayer money to put into the
destruction of the things that we rely
on and other other policies include
things like forcing big companies to
disclose kind of the the impact that
they're having on nature why should we
care
that's a good question and it's one that
I think scientists when I talk to
scientists about this I also struggled
to get a very clear answer I mean the
three ways I think you can look at it on
the very first level is that we pay for
it so we pay for it today in terms of
things like when pollinators die in food
prices rise
these going Birds going all of these
things mean that we're actually directly
suffering from the the added costs that
we don't we don't see we don't directly
notice it but it's happening there in
the background second thing is that it
could massively cause collapses of
systems so when we talk about things
like climate change we know things are
getting worse and worse and we know the
more that we heat the planet we know
that the worse it gets but with
biodiversity loss and Wildlife loss it's
on a whole nother level the chances of
just tipping an entire kind of ecosystem
on which we rely to get good food that
has massive consequences and so things
like pandemics becoming more likely as
we expand into untouched lands
essentially you can link things like
lockdowns over pandemics which we've
just become very used to over the last
few years
to things like the way that we treat
nature and I mean the third thing and I
don't want to make a light of this but
what I read this morning was that
pollinators for some crops are kind of
not really necessary so things like rice
and stuff like that Maize we can get by
if we don't have birds and wild bees
kind of pollinating things with other
crops there's a bit of dependencies so
fruit nuts avocados things like that but
with chocolate
chocolate is entirely dependent on wild
pollinators if you if you destroy nature
you don't have chocolate and that's not
just something that affects our kitchen
and like our snack at lunch it also
means entire Industries go clap get
collapsed okay so it really matters so
there's definitely a need for Urgent
action I know you're you're following
this further so we'll get updates from
you thank you so much